ministère russe de la défense a indiqué
que ses forces allaient désormais se
concentrer sur une libération complète
du donbass à l'est du pays il s'agissait
d'une des options de départ de
l'opération spéciale autres étant la
conquête de l'ensemble de l'ukraine a
rapporté l agence russe interfax
et juste mon reste en russie parce que
vu de russie et bien les informations
vous le savez c'est de la propagande et
pour décrypter elena volochine est avec
nous à nouveau notre correspondant en
russie elena bonsoir c'est quand il
fallait donc tous les soirs ces chaînes
de télévision russes et comment cette
propagande d'ailleurs montre la guerre
en ukraine et oui la propagande russe
parle bien de libération et on commence
avec l'info du jour il est 14 heures à
paris 16 heures à moscou voici
l'ouverture du journal sur la principale
chaîne d'information continue que
regarde la russie rossiya-24 bienvenue
dans la réalité parallèle stéphanie on
va l'écouter un peu en longueur mais
vous allez voir c'est important
depuis le 24 février les forces armées
de la fédération de russie mène une
opération militaire spéciale son but
principal est d'aider les peuples des
républiques populaires nous donnait ce
qui est de lougansk sous vide et 8 ans
un génocide par le régime de kiev dans
ces conditions il était possible d'aider
les répliques d'une donetsk de lougansk
que par la voie militaire mais c'est ce
qu'a fait la russie nous avions deux
options nous cantonner aux territoires
de la dlr et de la lnr dans les limites
celle d'istres hâtive des régions de
donetsk de lougansk pic et inscrire dans
les constitutions des républicains est
ce que hugh grant coeur busti jetons se
crêpe le nov mais dans ce cas nous
aurions été confrontée à un afflux
permanent des forces armées ukrainiennes
hochart de ce qu'ils appellent
l'opération des forces alliées c'est
pourquoi nous avons choisi la deuxième
option qui prévoyait des actions surtout
de territoire de l'ukraine ces actions
visaient à démilitariser ci ad nazifié
le cours des opérations a confirmé que
c'était la bonne décision le plan défini
par l'état major est respectée
alors ce général du ministère russe de
la défense qu'est ce qui nous explique
nous explique d'abord que il y avait un
génocide dans le dombass perpétrés par
les ukrainiens ça c'est ce qui justifie
a justement ce qui sert à justifier
cette opération de libération donc dans
laquelle s'est lancée la russie puisque
des nazis ukrainiens auraient cherché à
mener ce génocide contre les populations
russophones et donc on a attaqué
l'ukraine pour empêcher ce génocide mais
le terme attaqué le terme d'invasion on
est évidemment jamais prononcé dans la
par la propagande russe des actions qui
viennent qui visait donc à démilitariser
et des nazis fier et là on nous dit que
tout se déroule selon le plan prévu et
que si la russie ça c'est très important
c'est une information qui a été révélé
aujourd'hui c'est que si la russie a
attaqué toute l'ukraine c'était pour
empêcher l'armée ukrainienne de mener
une contre-offensive empêchant la russie
devenir libérer le dombass etc
république populaire de donetsk et de
lougansk voilà donc la théorie que l'on
apprend aujourd'hui on en apprend au
passage que peut-être la russie se
cantonnerait donc à récupérer dans leur
grande frontière administrative ces
régions de donetsk et de l'ogc entre et
l'autre message qu'a fait passer durant
ce briefing le ministère russe de la
défense c'est qu'on ne fait jamais de
victimes civiles on mène une guerre
propre selon la russie ce message est
repris tel quel par les journaux
télévisés russes écoutez
contrairement aux nationalistes qui
bombardent aveuglément les villes du
dombass y compris avec des missiles
ouragans les militaires russes font
usage d'armes de haute précision et ne
frappe que décider des infrastructures
de combat nos militaires font tout pour
que les habitants pacifique ne souffrent
pas et puis marion paulin ville meurtrie
assiégé elena depuis quasiment trois
semaines par les russes à écouter la
télévision russe on est dans une
opération humanitaire oui c'est ce que
nous martèle la propagande russe depuis
le départ c'est que marioupol cette
ville rasée par les bombardements russes
où il ya des muons ne sais pas combien
de victimes civiles mais qui vivent un
cauchemar absolu mais il faut bien que
les rues justifie ces dégâts causés à
marioupol alors on prétend que c'est
l'armée ukrainienne qui détruit la ville
qui retient les civils en otage qui
fusil ceux qui tenteraient de fuir et
que les russes eux essayent de venus en
aide à ces populations retenues par par
les ukrainiens écouter cet autre extrait
de journal de la première chaîne de
télévision russe
l'adn air annonce avoir pris le contrôle
de la moitié de la ville dans la partie
qui reste les nationalistes détiennent
les gens en otage et ne les laisse pas
partir ceux qui tentent de fuir sont
fusillés
alors que nous dit faut donc ce journal
c'est que l'adn r c'est république
séparatiste de donetsk à laquelle
devraient être rattachés marioupol selon
la russie et bien elle a repris le
contrôle quasiment de la moitié de la
ville il faut bien comprendre regardez
cette carte que marioupol pour vladimir
poutine ce n'est pas négociable et il va
tenter tout faire pour tenter de
reprendre cette ville parce que elle est
inscrite historiquement dans les
frontières de cette république
autoproclamée de donetsk qui a donc été
qui s'est déclarée séparer de l'ukraine
depuis le début de la guerre en 2014 et
donc marioupol ce port stratégique devra
être rattachés à cette république selon
la russie la grande question maintenant
est de savoir est ce que il y aura ce
corridor vers la crimée pour pour avec
ses villes de milito paul carson
notamment qui ont déjà été reprises par
l'armée russe mais en tout cas ce que
nous dit aujourd'hui d'après si on
écoute bien la propagande russe c'est
qu' il faudrait au moins que ces
républiques autoproclamées de donetsk et
de lougansk est bien soit restaurée dans
les frontières qu'elles ont autoproclamé
justement est d'ailleurs la propagande
russe a déjà battu les cartes parce que
lorsqu'on écoute les signatures des
reportages qui sont faits à marioupol
par les équipes de la télévision russe
regardez bien les sous titres
me disait tu le désires bien ce qu'ils
m'aideraient kinowski nathalie si droit
vers le canada n'y ait qu'une analyse
publica voilà vous voyez marioupol
c'était en république populaire de
donetsk déjà selon la télévision reja
comme si c'était donc un acquis
marioupol c'est donc une ville que
vladimir poutine se décidera
véritablement apprendre oui et ça
s'appelle une prophétie auto
réalisatrice et qui en l'occurrence va
se réaliser si vladimir poutine parvient
à ses objectifs au prix de milliers de
destin de civils anéanti merci lna